I'm not sponsored but I wanted to share
this quick review of this belly facial
hair removal tool that I got off of
Amazon because I was genuinely left
thinking where has this been all my life
and why have I never heard of it before
I've always plucked my facial hair just
because it lasts a whole lot longer than
shaving does and I'm not about to pay
for Waxing or constantly be like
replacing razors so plucking was the way
I went and this little tool what it does
is it basically pulls off your hairs but
it pulls out several at the same time I
already did it on my top so it might not
catch a whole lot but just to kind of
show you that it pulls out the here and
it pulls several ow and if people say
that it doesn't hurt they're lying it
does hurt I definitely had some like
ouch up here especially as I was trying
to get used to it but in order to
prevent uh irritation what I did was I
just washed my face with soap and water
you can use a cleanser and then I
followed up with either almond oil or
coconut oil or you can use whatever
lotion I definitely am going to be using
this because it's going to be saving me
time from having to pluck and it lasts a
whole lot longer so I'm glad that I
found this little tool hopefully it
helps